hallo mein name ist luca heute hat sich
ja eigentlich catcher pokémon go ist vor
einiger zeit für smartphone erschienen
und ist ein neues wiebels gehabt das
spiel wo man quasi mit dem handy einfach
durch die umgebung läuft dort irgendwo
ein pokemon dann sieht fangen kann
leveln kann arenen kämpfen kann wenn ich
jetzt war sie in der app drin sieht das
ganze hier ca so aus also wir können uns
hier umsehen sehen schon sie echte karte
also das ist real life gerade ein paar
sekunden später meine damen und herren
wir haben jetzt ein radfahrer gerade
hier gesehen und wir können jetzt
beispielsweise den pokal nehmen das
einfach auf das radfahren rausschmeißen
dass wir dann eingezogen und jetzt
können wir zählen
ich habe mein leben ist vorbei
ich habe jetzt nämlich das rad franz
gefangen und habe dafür 610 p bekommen
kann jetzt einfach aufdrücken dann wird
das quasi im kodex bei mir abgespeichert
ich habe fünf pokémon ich habe fünf von
15 pokemon 35 nicht richtiger ich bin
jetzt gerade hier bei pokemon level 3
ich heiße da laser luca rio weil alle
anderen haben schon vergeben waren die
pokémon die ich bisher habe sind
ratsfrau bogatz übertraf sie und lohmann
da habe ich keine also in dem spiel
nicht
ich habe schon ich bin aber kein ganz
normaler larry hughes über sondern ich
bin es tatum und wir besuchen jetzt eine
pokémon arena die eigentlich erst ab
level 5 geht aber wir gucken ob die uns
trotzdem rein lassen das wetter spielt
und gerade nicht so ganz in die karten
ich glaube es soll irgendwann regnen
aber wo sie das ganze hier mittlerweile
ich halt gerade einfach grundschul
sporthalle eine ahnung wie die heißt
aber da kommt menschen und hund von
hinten
wir befinden uns gerade in unmittelbarer
nähe von einem puck ist auch in
pokerchips kammern und was kann man da
machen keine ahnung ich hätte das spiel
nicht
hallo menschen guckt mich an weil diese
respekt vor mir
was war das gerade den jogger verfolgen
und dem angst an poker stoxx kammern
sowie ich das erfahren habe quelle
kaufen andere items kaufen und direkt
neben dem fokus auf sich direkt neben
dem christophorus nach arena das heißt
wir werden in diesem video versuchen
level 5 bei diesem pokémon go spiel zu
erreichen ohne die arena deren wir es
schaffen zeitnah aber das sollte glaube
ich machbar sein um halt levels hoch zu
kommen wir auf eine falsche richtung
hier wird gerade an gezeigt dass in der
nähe eigentlich keine pokémon sind das
ist natürlich traurig weil ich
eigentlich vollkommen im wald bin mir
hast du dieses spiel ist frisch gemähten
rasen
vielleicht finden wir im bisasam hier
meine damen und herren wir sind jetzt
beim poker stop angelangt jeder um die
scheiße
ok jetzt ist der poker ist ob wir können
da drauf klicken können dieses mädchen
hier drehen und dann passiert gerade gar
nichts doch wir haben ok mallory 3po
quelle ich bin halt kein pokémon go
profi ich muss ehrlich gesagt sagen ich
hab mir das spiel gestern erst runter
geladen unter dem bisschen gezockt weil
ich nicht so viel zeit hatte allerdings
glaube ich dass poker stop ist einfach
so sachen sind wo man hingehen kann und
sich da poker bälle holen kann und for
free und irgendwie dann jede halbe
stunde oder so würde ich mal so grub
behaupten wir befinden uns jetzt gerade
auf dem weg zu einer arena wo ein
elektro pokemon oben ist hier vorne ist
die arena hier befinden wir uns und wir
waren jetzt gerade beim post ob das
heißt wir laufen jetzt noch kurz
irgendwie 50 meter bis wir dann da
hinten irgendwo bei einer arena sind
viele fragen mich auch eher skeptisch in
pokémon trainer passt ja was macht dich
zu einem besseren trainer als alle
anderen auf der welt sagte sicher kennen
direkt auf etwas ein populist oder ein
gegenstand aus der natur geht eben
beispielsweise einen baum dem jetzt mal
versuchen zu können
der sarg wurde richtig großer hingehört
wir sind jetzt gerade an der arena
vorbei gelaufen die war wirklich direkt
davor eine brille mogel berühmt
ich weiß dass ich bin echt kettchen
anteilschein
da ich habe jetzt gerade einen kleinen
stein gefangen jetzt bewegt sich aber
noch 123 da wir jetzt hier nicht so
viele pokémon gefunden haben um genau zu
sein eigentlich fast gar kein haben wir
jetzt hier die möglichkeit einen rausch
altem hinzuschmeißen das heißt wir gehen
einfach kurz auf items auch hier oben
läuft derzeit 29 minuten 55 und hier
sollten jetzt gleich pokémon auftauchen
dieses pokémon
mein wille ist hauptziel freunde okay
wir versuchen jetzt mal mit dem ball zu
drehen dann bekomme ich mehr erfahrung
und voll daneben geworfen ich habe mir
sagen dass wenn wir den ball dreht und
dann so ein bisschen so von hier wirkt
so freue ich mich sogar auf die
historisch schlechteste pokémon das ist
etwas mehr da hinten denn jetzt
eigentlich rassen pokemon fragen der
verscheucht die lokale weiß man startet
mit zwei raushalten
da denke ich mir doch die sind etwas
wertvolles und ziehen dann liegen wir
richtig viele pokémon 1 wird bisher 17
in sieben minuten welser kingsley der
meine damen und herren wir haben als
nächstes pokémon nebenan direkt in der
1000 warum den mut auch zum anlass
100.000 likes darin sind mit scheiße
besprühten überall haben wir haben jetzt
hier ein taxi und können
die app ist abgestürzt
vielleicht daran dass noch einmal den
handy ein bus dabei geholfen hast du
dich vielleicht nicht mehr machen ich
habe jetzt gerade mal einfach die neue
modus an gemacht das heißt wir sehen
hier vorne ein habitat und können das
habe ich jetzt einfach mal ne frage
indem er den ball auf das habitat werfen
und
immer wenn ich irgendwas draußen auf mit
jedem scheiß typ wieder rad oder wir
haben im traktor um der moment der
wahrheit meine damen und herren einfach
durchs ob sie durch ich versuche das
jetzt mal einfach so zu fangen wehrte
den kopfball auf
herzlichen glückwunsch es noch mal
scheiße gefallen ein drittel klettert
jetzt einfach mal ein baum hoch so dass
omega wir haben habitat vorn ist das
habe ich versuchen sie erst mal mit dem
hyper real wieder es gucken vielleicht
im busch ich habe gehört wenn man die
teile dreht und dann wird dann wohl
heftig gut wir haben wieder hunderte
bekommt das macht unser level genau so
ein bisschen höher
liebe freunde wenn ihr weitere pokémon
go videos sehen wollt dann lasst einfach
mal ein like da schreibt mir die
kommentare waren europe ich hab grad
voll in die scheiße vom überfall gefasst
schreibt wenn meine kommentare ob ihr
schon sich dieser etwas euro pokémon
tipps sind welche pokémons ihr besitzt
hauptmann alles unten rein wenn ich dann
den nächsten fahrt aufnehme werde dann
werde ich dann dafür sorgen dass ich
irgendwie vorher schon wer will fünf
gekommen bin und dann werde ich im
nächsten partner line arena machen oder
so was in die richtung sonst würde ich
sagen sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
wenn es wieder heißt catcher jack poker
ball